did you ever meet Tupac yes we actually
were in a movie together now my scene
hit the cutting room floor but do you
remember the movie gang-related with Jim
Belushi that starred Tupac I was in that
film as well what was your did you play
you I played me as a hot dog vendor it
was during the first lockout and I was
supposed to have fallen on hard times
and that was a hot dog vendor but it
didn't make it it didn't make the movie
did you have dialogue i did with Tupac
and with Jim it was pretty funny
actually I can't believe it didn't make
it do you remember your lines no
absolutely nothing how are you my friend
good but what happened last night if
something go down that I'm not really oh
my god how do you use this is how do you
explain is why this is why I say the
two-minute report that's now coming out
that the officials come out and they
basically grade their performance in the
last two minutes this goes to what I've
always said about our game in the MV
officials especially in late game
situations that the officials always
swallow their whistle and let the
players decide the game as it reaches as
vows maybe or non calls they always let
the players decide the games and last
night was was no different there was two
calls obviously the okc spurs call but
there was a call in our game that i had
never seen before where they had to
huddle up and they were kind of
scratching their heads now they ended up
making the right call if you remember
the foul that i believe it was Shumpert
on Millsap that pushed Millsap into the
shooting Kyle Korver yeah while he was
shooting Therese well the foul occurred
on Millsap but they gave Korver the
three free throws it was almost like the
domino effect we had never seen that
before and I guarantee you that was one
of the main reasons why the officials
huddled up and came over the correct
call but that call in this first Thunder
no one had ever seen that before but
personal dion Waiters taking the ball
out of bounds which I don't want and
then you know Ginobili is on the line
you see his foot on the line crowding
him and then you get the forearm shiver
on the Westbrook is running out of
bounds and coming back inbounds I'm I'm
question if he could have caught the
basketball on that but Danny Green
fouled Kevin Durant on the ball was in
the air while Durant was going down that
was a foul that was not called if I was
Patty Mills I would a pump fake and let
Steven Adams run right into me that
would have been a foul and then the
offensive rebound by LaMarcus Aldridge
easily could have been a foul but again
I always say the officials swallow their
whistles and I'm not saying it's right
or wrong but it's always been that for
18 years that I played they let players
decide the game I know people are all up
in arms to me the blatant lie is to say
that they missed a call when the
official is counting you off and looking
right at you so how can you say you
didn't see dion Waiters elbow shove
whatever you want to describe it you
can't say that the official didn't see
it because the official is right on the
play behind counting the five seconds
that's what gets people so upset about
yeah and I understand that you could
have missed Ginobli foot being on the
line which if you start there with that
baby but again put on a line is just a
delay of game and then you restart what
waiters did if the change of possession
that changes thing that's become Spurs
ball timeout for the Spurs where
Popovich can drop a play and everyone
saying well they got the ball yes they
got the basketball but Witten you want a
timeout change of position where Popkin
drama play very much like he did to get
called which valve on a 3-pointer I
would take that as opposed to a scramble
play where you had the wrong people
taking the shot like Patty Mills in the
corner yeah you have a three on one you
gotta capitalize against Steven Adams I
did you know San Antonio said the San
Antonio should never been in that
situation where you need help to win
their game and one play does not define
a game I know everyone's all up in arms
it's time for us to move on it happened
it's not going to you know he's not
going to replay the game or those last
14 seconds and you're right a
three-on-one situation when Danny Green
got the ball instead of throwing it
ahead to Patty Mills he had Manu Ginobli
to his right if he would have passed the
ball to Ginobili it would've been a much
simpler flight because then you would
had a two-on-one or Ginobili almost had
a step or two in front of Steven Adams
where he probably would have got fouled
by Adams going in for the layin talking
to Reggie Miller NBA on TNT analyst he's
got game two of the hawks and Cavs
that's coming up wednesday night at
eight Eastern on TNT do you think that
Kevin Durant's future is attached to the
outcome in this series I do not and
that's easy for us to say because we're
on the outside looking in but obviously
he's had great success playing for the
Thunder winning an MVP getting to the
finals losing to the heat you know we're
quick to say oh you know if they lose
he's out of there or if they win you
know why would he stay the only person
really that could answer this question
and there's going to be so many suitors
out there from the Lakers to the next to
the heat to Boston there's so many
places to Washington going home there's
so many places in choices that Katie is
going to have but there's no place like
leaving his first home and that's OKC
Thunder the fans have been great and the
grass is not always greener once you
leave and you do know this yes I know I
hope he factors all this in to whatever
decision he's going to have to make what
you think a Luke Walton get the job of
the Lakers
for him look winning a championship or a
couple championships with the Lakers and
then winning one as an assistant under
Kerr and oh you know with the Warriors I
think it's this is great I think it's a
great hire now I just hope they don't
run the triangle there with that
personnel i think i think you said
they're going to try to incorporate
Golden State style okay that's better
who's in guys don't think those young
guys are ready for the triangle but he
turned down the Knicks to take the
Lakers why do you think well I think
Luke has always been a West Coast guy
you know he was raised in California and
I just I think he's the West Coast guy
you think it's as simple as that because
the Knicks are a better team now than
the Lakers but that doesn't mean they
don't have a draft pick you think so
like right now I would take the Knicks
roster against the lakers if they're
going to play a best of seven okay I'll
take the Knicks is this including the
incoming number one pick whether it's
ignorable or seven no no on time I right
now but I'd even give you Simmons if you
know you wanted to I got a chance to see
Simmons last night that is a tall dude
man I know you was that tall six you
guys on don't nobody fed again 68 69
about 69 but long and big shoulders I
didn't know you was that long you could
still take him oh stop all that you have
people all up in arms in this Memphis
people really thought we were serious i
said our turner team could I mean do you
think 3 50 year old I'm talking to you
all of Memphis and Tennessee do you
really think three this year old and to
40 something year old could really beat
you guys in a game I mean they really
thought we were serious Zach Randolph as
far as they were all like really up
strapless with with me I'm like are you
guys serious oh my god
uh I don't think they know your sense of
humor reg oh my god it's all good you
can somebody died on the court if that
actually happened yes we could you you
got Shaq running up and down the floor
Barkley run up down the police trying
after that after that little wrestling
match I saw between Jack and and TV I
don't know if I want either one of them
truthfully come on Shaq there's no way
you will let trial get back on top no
way the situation with the Warriors
night this is a big game for Portland
tonight because Steph Curry's planning
on or hoping to come back in Game three
what would change your opinion to not
have Steph Curry playing in Game three I
still would not play min game three
especially if the Warriors win Game two
I do not bring stuff back until the
warriors lose a game what is upset
almost like almost like Houston okay so
Portland they lost tonight three you
brought him back Game four okay right
yeah so I would not place that if they
win game two I would not play them in
game three I would not bring him back
until they lose a game I was watching
you know I know he's worried about his
rhythm but if he's fine to play in game
3 which means he's going to be doing a
lot of two on two three on three behind
the scenes so he'll start to get his
rhythm back I know game time action is
different but I want to era we're going
to need him vs. Russell Westbrook or
Kawhi Leonard more importantly right
isn't that more important I would think
yes okay so I don't bring him back until
they lose a game in that series Kyrie
Irving went off last night even though
the Cavs blew an 18-point lead but is he
a hundred percent like that because he
can be the difference maker for this
team obviously last year they were up to
one he goes down with a dislocated knee
but his importance to this team can you
count on it as a consistent is he a
hundred percent absolutely and he's got
that explosive first step back he's
raining down threes I thought I'd never
see this he turn
jeff Teague around a couple times yeah
think about this he was the leading
scorer in that first round vs detroit
and that's surprising obviously because
you have lebron james on that team
because we had to go back the last time
the Ron didn't lead a team in a series
in scoring was in 2011 when they lost to
the mavs in the finals Dwyane Wade let
that team in scoring so it's been a
while for LeBron James and look if
you're LeBron this is what you've always
hoped and wished you got Kevin Love
Kyrie Irving to take the pressure off of
yourself so no he's back and uh the
question is can he and love stay healthy
love got banged up anyone he was limping
so we'll have to see the limp the
shoulder it was the racial or not the
left shoulder that was repaired so we'll
have to see you know how he's moving in
Game two LeBron's going to do a remake
of space jams is that right that's what
we're hearing did were you you weren't
in the original with Michael I was not
but I was part of the Jordan domin we
were all summoned from his greatness to
come work out wait boy to do we weren't
summit I did it for selfish reasons
because that was the only reason why I
was going up there to work out they
built a basketball dome for Michael
Jordan as he was filming space gym so he
would film all day and then we would
come up at like eight or nine at night
to play pick-up games so I went up there
for selfish reasons because I had to try
to look he was killing me I had to find
a tail on this dudes go there and try to
find the tail you know try to be look as
much as we were going to because you
never get a chance to play one on one
and five on five so that's where you can
kind of find out what certain guys like
or dislike but Theodore didn't help good
fun I couldn't find a tail but it was
some of the best runs we ever had well
Grant Hill says that he went up there I
think and put it all over Jordan and
then told his friends about it and then
the next time he went he said Mike just
completely humiliated me
um he has a way of doing that yes yes
but it was funny because I I said to
myself you know I'm not gonna go up
there and work out of him you know look
it you know that the respect I have for
MJ but you know how much I hated him you
know sounds like I can go work off with
that dude are you kidding me off like
believing he could do your homework
maybe you could find out something and
like a dummy I'm going up there you know
three or four times a week working out
with this dude and come season I'm like
okay I'm ready I got it it was totally
different he was playing totally
different damn him reg we'll have Game
two Wednesday night between the hawks
and the Cavs that's 8 Eastern on TNT uh
thanks for joining us reg and we'll talk
to you soon Theodore you're the best
love you do that thank you bud the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience